being bigger in America will mean that
we will be big everywhere else
football is and how I think it is the
same everybody has his own styie like to
be me it's kind of effortless the way he
stands apart in the way he kind of is
his own individual that is what I'm
excited about capturing take this huge
wall put some paint one of the best
athletes on the planet wallings world
club combine it all together and we got
some beautiful beautiful art you know
you think about New Orleans you think
about the culture I think this is the
perfect space for athletes that's
creative spontaneous as Paul Pogba yeah
that's me for sure to love to dance you
know try to put this in football he
might as well be from the wall is the
way he moves and greens looking at the
way he always uses his hair as his own
canvas I'd like to be different I like
to be myself I like to be me
so I found a moment of his hair
evolution where he had these these very
bold shapes on the side of his hair but
the top was growing upwards I wanted to
create this image of growth I think that
people don't judge me more because of
the outside football which has nothing
to do with people they can have their
own opinion it doesn't matter either I
arrived here how I wanted I played
football I want these flowers are native
to France French lilies which are also
for leaf
both France and wallings has this huge
fascination with
that flower and very proud to wear the
shirt was proud to play for my country
it's a dream come true every time just
woke up you have a nice group you have
everything to go and ridden as far as
soccer fan base goes New Orleans is an
emerging space for it people are
starting to really celebrate and embrace
it it's infectious in a way it's hard to
not be a fan when you're around it or
you see it so I'm hoping that this
painting becomes a part of that tipping
point that makes soccer a more
celebrated sport in this city I would
like to be perceived with oh really
that's a nice question it's just as a
human just want to be normal
[Music]